>> Anytime Waterloo
reminiscing [inaudible].
>> So, thank you all for coming.
It's really a pleasure to
be hosting Dr. Jesse Hoey here
at Microsoft Research, Montreal.
So, Dr. Hoey is as
some of you may know,
an associate professor in
the David Cheriton School
of Computer Science at
University of Waterloo,
where he leads the computational
human intelligence laboratory.
He holds a PhD from
the University British Columbia,
has published over a 100
peer-reviewed scientific papers and
has received a number of awards
including from Microsoft,
have to talk about that one.
The AAI and the International
Association for pattern recognition.
He's also for the American
Sociological Association.
I think he maybe one of
the only computer scientists
that I know of who
has two articles in
the American Sociological
Review which is
the best sociological review
in states possibly the world.
So, he's very interdisciplinary.
He's an area chair for the
International Joint conference on
our [inaudible]
Artificial Intelligence and
was the program chair and
the 10th EAI International
Conference and Pervasive Computing.
He'll be speaking today on
social and emotional
Artificial Intelligence.
So, please welcome Dr. Hoey.
>> All right. Thanks, Luke
and thanks for inviting me here
and hosting me this visit.
So, Montreal is my hometown.
So, it's always nice
to come back here
and see how things have
changed a little bit.
So, I'm going to talk to you
about Artificial Intelligence,
but my perspective on it might
be a little bit different
than the mainstream view
of AI these days.
But I'll start with this slide with
some pictures of
some big achievements in AI.
So, obviously Artificial
Intelligence has come a long
way from computers they
could be chess grandmasters.
This is quite a while ago now to
self-driving cars and computers that
can play much more challenging
games nowadays.
But, one of the things if we look at
Artificial Intelligence
in group behavior,
then the situation looks
a little bit different.
So, this is a picture from
the 2017 robot cup which
is probably the quintessential
multi-agent problem.
These robots are playing on a team,
so it is funny because
they're robots and they're
a little bit difficult to
maintain a standing
and things like that.
But, they do know that
they're playing on
a team and they probably have
some centralized controller,
but they really have
no notion of what
being a team member means, right?
What essentially they lack is
any idea of empathy or culture
or emotion or altruism.
So, they don't have a way of
interpreting what other agents or how
other agents are handling
the situation as team members,
as a social group.
There has been some efforts
to make this happen.
So, let's try to put some emotional
behaviors into our robots.
So, here's this guy who's happy
and now he's not so happy,
maybe he'd let in a goal
or something like that.
But, of course, these are
just purely scripted behaviors.
This robot has no idea what
this means to any other robot.
In fact, no other robot has
any other way of interpreting
these signals, okay?
If you look at humans when
they play games together,
you see this vast array
of emotions going on.
So, this is a short clip
from the- this is
the bursa junior team that
just beat this Korean team.
You can see this incredible array
of emotions going on and
different cultural signals that
they're sending to each other.
Like this guy is using
the face slap which must be
some Spanish expression of empathy.
I'm not sure it works so well with
this Korean guy there is kind-.
So anyways, the bottom line is
that Artificial Intelligence has
come a long way and we can do
some remarkable things with it,
but when we get to the point
where AI or robots or
Artificial Intelligence
systems are trying to
interact with humans or
with groups of humans,
the situation looks quite different.
So, this is a well-known problem.
If you look at self-driving
cars, for example,
self-driving cars
have some difficulty
when they get to busy intersections,
for example, and one
of the reasons that
they have difficulty is that they
can't display enough aggression
to get through the intersection.
So, this cartoon by the oatmeal
is meant to sort of
lampoon that a little bit.
This is a situation where
this Google car is trying to
negotiate passage with this human
through an intersection.
You've probably all have
been in this situation where
you don't know who's
going to go next and
somebody's going to take
the bull by the horns and drive
forward and that aggression level
is a culturally determined thing.
So, if you go to different cultures,
people have different ways
of doing this.
So, in this situation,
the humans like making this way too
complicated and the robot has
no idea of what's going on.
The bottom line is that these robots,
these self-driving cars have
no model of how a human works.
Okay. So, they have
no human model in them.
They have models of how
things move in the world,
but they don't have
a model of something
like the level of
aggression that's needed to
get through an intersection.
So, Artificial Intelligence
has taken a stab
at putting emotions into
Artificial Intelligence Systems.
This has coined this term
that's used to describe this
as Affective Computing.
So, here I have a picture of,
I don't know why put Von Neumann
there but anyways there he is.
He didn't work on emotions so much,
but Herb Simon was probably
the first person to think
seriously about how could you
put emotions into a machine,
what would that mean?
He basically described
emotions as being
something that disrupts cognition.
So, we're thinking
all these high-level thoughts
and we're reasoning about what to do
next and then emotions come
in and disrupt everything.
But the disruption is
there for a reason.
Enables us to better
coordinate with other
human beings, for example.
Then Rose Picard wrote the book,
I guess wrote the book
on Affective Computing
1997 and the book
starts with this quote,
"This book proposes that we give
computers the ability to recognize,
express and in some cases
have emotions,
is this not absurd?"
So, in 1997, nobody had
really thought this
before written it down and it did
seem very absurd but she
was a professor at MIT.
So, she could get away with
saying absurd things I guess.
Since then the field has
grown and we're just now and
IEEE Transactions on
Affective Computing
and there's a couple
of major conferences.
So, there's a fair bit
of work in the area.
Rose Picard gave a talk
at AAAI in 2017,
describing some of her
amazing work on using wearables
to detect emotions for
healthcare applications.
They've really done
some amazing things in doing that.
But if you look at
Artificial Intelligence,
so for example, in the 2017 AAAI,
I looked through all of
the titles when she was giving
this talk and found the word
emotion appeared three times.
That's three times in
about a thousand papers.
The same thing in 2018.
So, I feel like the study
of emotions has been pushed
a little bit to the side by a lot
of the recent developments in AI.
But it'll make a comeback.
Okay. So, I think that the view that
Herb Simon proposed which
has sort of been largely,
what a lot of effective
computing has worked from,
that emotions are
sort of disrupters of cognition.
I think that this may actually
be fundamentally backwards.
I'll try to explain why,
and then I'm going to give in
this talk a model that I think
puts the cart before the sorry,
puts the horse before the cart
instead of the cart before the horse.
So, I try to motivate it with
some evidence that we have
from neurophysiology.
So, this is a very
highly stylized picture
of what's going on
in the human brain,
and from this paper
by Zhu and Thagard.
What they do is, they describe
two different systems that
happen in human cognition.
They call it a low
road and high road.
The low road is something that is
these are both cognitive processes.
So, these are not instinctive things.
These are actually things
that humans reason about but,
the low road is something that takes,
avoids the large parts
of the sensory cortex
and is something that
happens very very quickly,
and is able to give human beings
a rough idea of what to do next.
Okay. Then the high road
is a pathway through
the brain that takes longer,
but then it goes through
these cortical reasoning aspects,
and that's where you do
your actual cognitions and
thinking about how the world
works, and so on and so forth.
The interplay between these
two systems is really
quite an interesting part of how
humans make decisions
and act in the world.
With again this low road
providing this very fast, quick,
and dirty solutions to things,
and this high road coming in later if
necessary and trying
to fix things up.
Right. You see the same,
the same idea of two systems coming
out from psychology and
behavioral economics.
So, perhaps the most famous example
of this is this book
by Daniel Kahneman;
Thinking Fast and Slow,
where he describes these
two systems again.
The Fast System 1 which operates
automatically and quickly,
and then the Slow System 2 which is
Effortful Mental Activity
and Complex Calculations.
The way that they work together in
Kahneman's work or what he's
just how he describes it,
is that this System
1 is the thing it is
always in operation that
humans are using to get by.
Then when that runs into trouble,
people call this System 2 into
play in order to help them
figure out what to do.
Right. But people do not want to go
and use this System 2 because
it takes more energy.
If you can avoid using
it, might as well.
You get by with much less
if you can go with this.
You see the same idea throughout
a vast array of
different disciplines.
People running into
the same concept of
these two systems in
the brain. All right.
So, this is what I see as
the traditional view of emotion
in Artificial Intelligence,
which essentially is what
Herb Simon was talking about.
So, you have some of the environment,
you perceive what's going on,
then you have your
cognitive systems that are
reasoning about the environment,
what's happening.
So, you're playing chess and
you're figuring out where
all the chess pieces are and
how you're going to
move them, and so on.
Then that drives you
to take some action.
Then your emotions or
things that are happening
kind of on the side after the fact.
So, after you sorted out everything
that's going on in the world,
then you figure out what emotion
you should be feeling,
and then you have that emotion
and that can modify
how you're thinking about
the tasks that you're doing.
So, really a cognitive machine
disrupted by by emotion.
Again these disruptions that
the emotion causes may be useful.
Right. They may be
actually pointing you in
a direction that may be useful to go,
but really they are,
take second place to this,
this higher-level cognitive
reasoning engine.
The theory that I'm
going to describe today
really reverses these two systems,
and I think puts the affect of
processing system as the thing that
has the first kick at
the can, so to speak.
Right. So, these perceptions come in,
they go straight into
our affective reasoning engine.
This generates an immediate action.
This is what I should do next.
The key behind this
affective reasoning engine,
is that it provides an action,
a course of action to take
which is the one that is
most socially reasonable
in the situation.
After that, if this breaks down,
then people can call in these
higher level cognitive processes
in order to figure
out how to fix this.
Right. So, okay.
So, that's the sort of
very high level view.
This is an emotional machine which is
disrupted by cognition. Yeah.
>> It is a part what is affective
here and what is just
sort of a quick,
a muscle memory like a confidence
computation already before.
>> Right.
>> We're separating those two.
>> Yeah. We're separating those two.
So, I guess there's actually
a third system here which I'm
not putting in which
bypasses all of this.
Right. So, you could draw another
arrow that is this immediate.
So, that's when if I jump
at you and you jump back,
that's your instinctive muscle memory
to avoid things coming
at you, for example.
That's not what this
is talking about here.
This is still a cognitive process.
The theory that I'll
describe to you is,
this cognitive process
relies heavily on language.
So, on how we interpret the world in
terms of symbols, essentially.
Right. Or linguistic concepts.
Any other thoughts or questions?
So, I'm going to now
describe to you this theory,
and then I'll give you
a few examples of how I've
I've gotten it working in
a couple of different contexts.
So, how are we going to do this,
is I'm going to look back at
this work by Osgood in the '50s.
So, Charles Osgood who
was a psychologist
who did these amazing experiments
and he went around the world and
asked people to rate concepts.
So, basically words in the language,
but he did this in
many different cultures.
So, different languages.
He got people to rate them on
what are called semantic
differential scales.
Semantic differential scales
are just a scale
with two opposing words at each end.
Right. So, angular to rounded,
or weak to strong,
or rough to smooth.
Right. He asked people,
he'd give them a word like in
this case the word polite,
and say, put a check mark on each of
these scales where you
think politeness sets.
What's amazing is that there's
this incredible degree of
consistency amongst humans
that share the same language,
that are in the same cultural group
as to where these words should go.
So, this picture show one of
the diagrams from his study in 1952,
showing two groups of 20 people.
This is the mean of
two groups of 20 people.
You can see this amazing
degree of consistency.
Everybody agrees.
Right. So, what's amazing
about that is that,
if you look at the word polite
and you look at some of these scales,
so you might wonder,
what is politeness
has to do with being
rougher, being smooth?
Right. Like, it seems to
be unrelated in some way,
at least on a semantic level
but, everybody agrees.
Yeah. Politeness is more sort
of smooth and rough.
Right. So, there's something really
interesting going on
here that everybody has
this implicit that we all share
these ratings of things on
these different scales.
So, what he did was,
he did these studies
and he actually used
many more dimensions than this.
So there's, I think on the order of
like 150 dimensions that he
used or 150 of these scales.
Then he went back and did
a dimensionality reduction and
found that he could account for
over 80 percent of the variance and
all this data with
just three dimensions.
The three dimensions
are one dimension of
evaluations of good to bad,
one dimension of power,
so strong to weak,
and one dimension of activity,
so hyper to asleep.
I'm going to put this one
coming out of the board.
So, bigger things are more hyper.
So, when you get
people to rate words,
they all agree on where they should
go in this three-dimensional space.
So, for example, being
polite is good and powerful
and being abusive is weak
and bad, and really active.
Right. So, this is a better word.
Being serene is good and
weak and really inactive.
You could do the same thing
with identities.
So, students and professors
for example is a good,
that's a good example.
So, students are, everybody
agrees that students are,
students and professors are
about the same goodness.
Right. But maybe
professors are a little
bit more powerful than students,
and students are maybe a bit
more active than professors.
Right. This is culturally dependent.
Right. So, if you go
to Japan for instance,
then professors are typically seen
as significantly more
powerful than students.
Right. So, but if you
come to North America,
then this has sort of
become normalized.
Students and professors
are seen as much
more equal on this power dimension,
and behaviors as well.
So, apologizing to somebody and
fighting with somebody, and so on.
So, this is actually real data
taken from a study done
in 2003 in the United States.
So, these are the means of,
I put the words that the means of
where people rate these concepts.
Again, I'll just reiterate that
the important thing to remember here,
is that everybody in
the cultural group agrees on
where these words should go in
this three-dimensional space.
Okay. So, how are we going to
take this idea, and leverage it,
and turn it into a
control principle that
we can use to drive
an artificial agent.
We're going to do that using
this Affect Control Theory,
and what Affect Control Theory
says is that people
carry around these
fundamental sentiments.
The fundamental sentiments
are these things here.
This is everybody's agreement
on where things should go
in this very simple just
three-dimensional space.
When a social action occurs,
so something happens in the world.
So, for example, maybe in
this case here we have a nurse,
and here's a nurse dumping
some water on this guy's head
and here's a nurse helping
this lady, for example.
These social actions create what
are called transient impressions.
So, the transient impressions are
also culturally shared things.
They are how you feel
about the situation.
So, how you feel about these things
in context, all right.
The transient impressions may be
different from these
fundamental sentiments and
the difference is called
the deflection, in this theory.
The Affect Control Principle
says that people try to
experience events that confirm
fundamental sentiments.
So, essentially they try
to reduce this deflection.
Affect Control Theory is
a consistency theory.
It says that we will try,
people will basically do the thing
that leads them to
situations where things are
emotionally consistent and
the consistency is defined
by a culturally shared construct,
which I'll show you in a second.
I'm going to go through a couple
of levels of increasing detail of
this theory and this is at the
high the highest possible level.
But interrupt me anytime if
you have questions as we go.
But I'll show you a bit more detail
of this as we go along.
It's all described in
this really nice book by David Hayes
who I guess is the guy who's
done many many years of
work on this theory starting
from the work of all is good
and many others as well
and describing this really
nice little book called
Expressive Order.
One of the interesting things
about this book is that it comes,
it has two parts.
The first part is
all the social psychological part
and it's tasked and it
describes his working in
looking at a variety of
different cultural groups and
how they follow these dynamics,
and in the second part
is a mathematical model.
What's interesting is when you
talk to most sociologists,
they've all read the first
part of the book
but ignored the second part.
So, they don't tend to
have that math background.
When I read it, I read
the first part of
the book and I was completely lost.
I didn't know where it was going on.
But then I read the second part,
I was like oh, this
makes total sense.
So, this is why it's good to have
a multi-disciplinary group
working together.
Here's a little bit more detail.
Affect Control Theory uses
a very simple grammar of an
actor behaving on an object.
The object is often another person.
People have these
fundamental sentiments
about each of these three things.
This is a nine dimensional vector
and it's according to the theory,
these vectors lie in the range
minus 4.3 plus 4.3 and I've asked
every sociologist I've met
who works in this theory of
why it's 4.3 and
nobody seems to know.
I think it's lost in
the sands of time but it
does have something to do with all
is good's original experiments.
It's actually not important
and the versions that I work
with this not restricted
to be in this range,
and you can re-scale it
to any that you want it.
When you see an actor
behaving on an object,
it creates a transient impression
for each of them as well,
and this is again gives you
a nine dimensional vector
in the same space.
The predictions of the transients
from the fundamentals are
given by this non-linear operator
which I'll show you in a second,
and this is something that
is also culturally shared.
Everybody agrees on how
these impressions are created.
The deflection is then
just the Euclidean distance between
fundamentals and transient,
and The Affect Control
Principle says that
actors work to reduce
this deflection.
You can use this as a control
principle because you can say part
of this sentiment is a behavior.
So, you can say what is the best
behavior to take in order to make
this actor and this object
agree emotionally to be
doing something emotionally
that's consistent.
So, you can use this deflection
measure as an optimization service
that you can walk down to find
the optimal behavior to take.
Affect Control Theory also has
a very precise definition of
emotion which is remarkable.
This is, I think,
the only theory I've ever seen
that has such a precise definition.
The emotions are described
as being proportional to
the vector difference between
fundamentals and transients.
People use emotions as
a communicative signal to
tell the person that
they're interacting
with where that person
is getting it wrong.
So, if I'm interacting
with you and you're not
treating me how I think I should
be treated, in this situation,
I'll send you an emotional signal in
order to help you correct for that,
and so that we can
come to an agreement
on how we're supposed
to be behaving. Yeah.
>> [inaudible] I guess a vector.
>> It's a vector in the same
three-dimensional space. Yeah.
>> So, yeah, I guess
different emotions like happiness,
sadness [inaudible] are
these points in space?
>> That's right. They would
be a point in the space.
If you look back at here,
that's why these emotion words
are in the same space.
The nice thing about
this three-dimensional space
is that you can compare
all these different entities in
the same space of behaviors,
identities, emotions.
They are all comparable directly,
with a simple
three-dimensional vector.
Here's the little bit more detail.
So, we have a social
interaction happening here.
Here's our nurse and our patient.
We've already done
a population survey.
So, we've asked people,
what do you feel about a nurse,
and we've gathered a rating for
nurses which is this one here.
So, nurses are seen as 2.9,
1.5, 0.2, for example.
Then we've asked them
about patients and
patients are a little bit less good,
much less powerful,
and much less active.
How about comforting,
the behavior of comforting?
Well, that's positive and
powerful and not very active.
Given these fundamental sentiments,
we compute a transient impression
for each of the three and
the transient impression is given by
a series of equations with
polynomial features in them.
So, the polynomials are basically,
these polynomial features
are combinations of
these different elements in
the fundamental sentiment.
So, this one here is
the evaluation of
the behavior multiplied by
the evaluation of the object,
and then it has a positive
coefficient and that's
the effect on the
evaluation of the actor.
What this term says is that if
the actor does something
good to a good person,
then they will seem more good.
These coefficients
are things that are
also culturally shared
and measurable.
So, we can ask people,
how do you feel about a nurse,
how do you feel about a patient,
how do you feel about
the act of comforting,
a nurse when you
see a nurse comforting a patient ,
and that measures
this transient impression
and then they can do a regression
and find these coefficients,
and find that they are
again shared culturally.
So, the difference between
these two things is the deflection.
Like I said before, I can use that
to predict the next behavior.
So I can optimize over
this deflection measure
in order to have
compute the best behavior to take.
I can also compute
a re-identification of
the nurse and the patient.
So, I can say, if I see
somebody comforting
a patient, who might that be?
Well, that's probably a nurse.
So, I can do that as well.
Before we go to an example
which might help
clarify some of this, any questions?
All right. So, let's
walk through an example.
I will use this
nurse-patient example.
Here's our nurse and our patient.
Again, here's their 3-D
evaluation potency
and activity fundamental sentiments.
Remember, these are
culturally shared.
I'll just keep reiterating that,
so we're sure we remember it.
The nurse is up here,
and the patient is here.
The important thing is that
the nurse knows that she is here
and knows that the patient
is here and the patient
knows that she's here and
knows that the nurse is here.
They both agree on that.
So, I can compute.
Well, let's see what
happens if the nurse
comforts the patient.
So, I compute the transient
impressions which are in light blue,
and you can see they're quite close
to the fundamental sentiments,
and then I can compute
what emotions would
be felt and communicated.
The nurse who comforts
the patient would feel
compassionate and the patient
would feel serene.
The reflection is low,
it's a 1.3 so that's
a low deflection.
But let's say we make
the nurse ignore the patient.
Here's a nurse who's
ignoring a patient.
Ignoring is quite negative
and not very powerful.
Now, the nurse seems much more bad
than a normal nurse would seem.
We'd say, "Well, who is this?
This is not a very nice nurse.
She's ignoring this poor patient."
But the patient also
seems more bad because,
well, maybe this patient has
been a really nasty patient.
That's why the nurse is ignoring her.
So, we construct all of these things,
but we do so just by computing
these transient impressions.
It's a very simple calculation.
The emotions that will be created or
agitation for the nurse
and the indignant,
patient feels indignant, "How dare
you ignore me, I'm the patient."
Remember, these are
the signals that each
would send to the other in
order to correct for this.
So, the patient would send
this vector to the nurse and
say to the nurse
essentially by sending
that emotional signal which
humans can do very quickly,
"Hey, listen, I'm
supposed to be up here
and you're treating me
like I'm down here,
and I'm telling you
exactly how you're
treating me by sending
you this vector."
The nurse can take that and say,
"Right, I got it wrong.
I thought you were horrible patient
but really you're not."
So, I'll correct for that
and do something to make it
better. Deflection is high.
>> [inaudible] so if
you ignore again.
>> Yeah, so what it means on
the behaviors is that you
may interpret the behavior.
If you're seeing what's happening,
then you're at least made
I'm sure that's a nurse, and
I'm sure that's a patient.
Maybe she's not ignoring the patient.
You seek an interpretation
of the situation that makes
it emotionally consistent.
So, the transient impression
would be one way
of getting that from the behavior.
So, for example, well, you see here,
this has gone up in evaluation,
and it's gone up in power.
So, one possible, well,
maybe this is not,
I don't know what word
would be close to
this transient impression but it's
probably something last like
ignoring, something more positive.
Well, maybe she's busy and just
come back to this patient later or
something like that. That make sense.
All right. Here's, another example.
This is a student and
a automated tutor.
This is one of the early examples
that we built with this theory.
The student and the tutor are,
this is student and professor,
they're in the same spot
but maybe the tutor
has a bit of power over the student.
So, we can compute. Well, what
would a student do to a professor.
Well, the student would do something
like this EP and A rating,
and I can look up in
my dictionary of sentiments
that I've had rated by
people and find this behavior or
the student might ask
something to the tutor.
Then, the deflection is low.
The transients are close to
the fundamentals, and
everything's good.
What if the tutor
yells at the student?
This creates transient impressions
that are very far from
these fundamentals.
Maybe this student is really a lot
more or less is a bad student,
or maybe this is a horrible tutor.
The obvious, what emotion would
be felt or maybe this
tutor is angry and
this student would be exasperated or
remorseful. Then we can compute.
Well, what would
the student do in order to
try to correct for this situation.
Well, they would maybe listen to
the tutor and feel self-conscious,
and this acts by the student
would help it to restore
his transient
impressions back towards
its fundamental sentiments but not so
much for the tutor because
the jury is still up.
The student doesn't know maybe
this tutor is really
a nasty tutor after all.
But if the tutor then does something,
so this is the computation,
the optimization for the deflection.
So, it's minimizing this deflection.
Well, what would the tutor do?
Something like apologize to
the student and now they
manage to get back to
somewhere where the
deflection is fairly low.
So what I did here
in this example was,
I forced the tutor to
yell at the student.
That's not an action that
Affect Control Theory
would compute because it
creates so much deflection.
I create that artificial
action and then
compute what's the optimal thing for
the student to do to
try to fix things,
and then what's the optimal thing for
the tutor to do to try
to fix things even more.
>> [inaudible].
>> Yeah, there could be
circumstances where
it's appropriate, yeah,
and people could yell at each
other for a variety
of different reasons.
One of them is, maybe not yelling at,
maybe that's a little bit too strong.
Yeah. One of the things that
happens when deflection
goes up is that this system
to thinking kicks in.
So, when there is a inconsistency
on the emotional.
So, the basic idea is that,
if I'm operating, this is
like an equilibrium theory.
So, if we're on
the same page and we're
operating according to
this emotional model,
as long as everything stays
at that equilibrium point,
then we'll just keep doing that.
It's really easy. You
don't have to think.
You just have to operate in
this simple three-dimensional space.
As soon as things go
off the rails though,
then you kick in this higher
level cognitive reasoning.
One of the things
that that might help
with is that it might force
the student to actually think
about what they're learning,
for example, and then they would
actually consider it and take
the information in instead of just
ignoring it and pretending
like everything's fine.
So, that could be one reason. Yeah.
>> So, just, I guess maybe to
continue on the light
of what you just said,
is there an implication
may be that in
some scenarios there's
utility in having
high deflection because
it forces you to engage
that higher level system and start
thinking more deeply about something?
>> No, there could be for sure.
Yeah. I'll talk about that
a bit more in a second.
But Affect Control Theory
doesn't have a utility function.
The version that I've developed,
which I'll show you next,
does but Affect Control Theory
is only describing what's happening
at that equilibrium point.
So, let's talk about utility
again after I show you this.
>> [inaudible] .
>> Right.
>> So the teacher
needs to [inaudible].
>> Right.
>> Have something [inaudible]
>> Yeah, yeah.
A student staring at the window
is not being a very
good student, right?
So, they're already off the
equilibrium point, all right?
>> I'm just trying to think of
it. Is there a circumstance
where an action is negatively
one context, but positive enough?
>> Yes, I try to think
of a good example there.
>> [inaudible] any action at the [inaudible]
equilibrium is forbid in any action?
>> Yeah.
>> We're just looking at yells at
[inaudible] lower left quadrant.
So, the student wasn't [inaudible].
It seemed like they yelled
at bring into equilibrium?
>> This getting a transient
that is here from here is
only based on this point.
So, if the student
was actually up here,
then yelling out wouldn't necessarily
bring them in the same spot, right?
But you're right. It could be
something along those lines.
Maybe a better example is,
the work that's done in
cognitive therapies for depression.
So a depressed person
is someone who has
a very negative sense
of who they are,
so they feel kind of
negatively about themselves.
For many years people thought that,
the way to handle this was to blast
the person with positive thoughts.
That doesn't work very well,
and the reason it doesn't work
very well is because you're not
treating the depressed person
like a depressed person.
That's how they think they are.
So the self-verification theory
came along and said that, "Well,
what you need to do is
agree with the person
that the world is terrible
and that everything sucks,
" and then you say,
"Yes, this is the way you are."
I am verifying your sense of who
you are as a depressed person.
So, I'm performing negative actions,
but I'm doing it in a
way in order to get us
basically at that point
of emotional alignment.
Then, from there, I'm going to
slowly try to work you in a direction
where you hopefully become
less depressed, for example.
That makes sense? Okay. All right.
So, my work in this has been to
develop a version that adds
a couple of new pieces to this.
One is a utility function,
and the other one is modeling
identities and behaviors as
probability distributions.
So, of course, it's not the case
that everybody does agree
exactly on where these concepts
sit in this three-dimensional space.
So, when you make these measurements,
you actually get a fairly big
variance around the mean.
So everybody does agree on the mean,
but there's a lot of disagreement
on where they would go, okay?
There's various turns out
to be very very important.
So it's something that
people I believe use,
in order to handle
operating in groups.
So, the problem with
group behavior is
that everybody is different,
there's this diversity.
Even if you're in
a single cultural group.
So, we as academics are often in
groups that involve
many different cultures.
But even if we're in
a very uniform cultural group,
there's all sorts of
differences because
people are interacting
with each other in
many different circles
and it's sort of maybe in
a small world type social network.
Because of that, there's lots of
uncertainty that comes into play,
and we need to be able to model
that uncertainty in order
to use this kind of idea,
this emotional consistency to
cooperate with other people.
Okay. So, those are
the two pieces and I'll walk you
through how this works as well.
Quite a few number of papers on it,
but two of the journal papers,
one in Artificial
Intelligence, the other one,
as we've pointed out in
the American Sociological Review,
and this paper won two awards
at the ESA meetings in 2016.
All right. So, the model is based on
a partially observable
Markov decision process,
so I'll give you what
this is all about,
and then we'll see how we can fit
this affect control theory piece
onto a generic model of how an
agent interacting with the world.
So, upon DP or
partially observable Markov decision
process consists of a set of
states X and a set
of observations that we can
make about those states.
So, these are unobservable
or latent states.
A set of observations.
We have an observation function,
which is a probability distribution
relating these two things.
There is a set of actions
that an agent can
take that changed the world according
to some transition function,
which is another
probability distribution.
Then, we have some reward or
utility function that describes
the agent's preferences
over these states,
using a numeric scale.
Okay. So, that's the generic model.
You can use this to do
a number of different things,
and maybe the simplest
way of visualizing how
you can use a POMDP
to generate a plan,
is to just do a very,
very simple forward search.
In general, this doesn't work,
but this is a way of
describing what you
actually are trying to do.
So here we are in our current state,
and remember this state since this X,
are sort of interpretation
of the world, is latent.
We can't observe it directly,
then the state that we're in
is actually a belief state,
so this is a probability distribution
over all possible states.
From this state, my agent
has a number of different actions
that it can take,
which lead it to another belief
state after taking the action.
Then, the other person
that the agent is
interacting with has a bunch
of things that it can do,
and that leads to another state,
and so on and so forth.
Down somewhere in this tree
is some rewards, let's say.
Then, I can draw this whole tree
out, find these rewards,
and then propagate them
back up through the tree
waiting them by the probability
of these things happening.
Then, I can use that to rank
the actions that my agent has,
and pick the one that optimizes
the over the utility function.
So that's just basic Bayesian
decision theory. All right.
So, what's the problem
with doing this,
of course, is this tree.
You can't write it
out, it's way too big.
These branching factors
are colossal, right?
So, if you tried to do this,
you'd rapidly run
into major problems.
A lot of the work in reinforcement
learning and decision theory
is how do you expand
this tree in a smart way,
so that you don't wind up having
to draw the whole thing out.
So, for example, you
can do things, well,
as far as what the other
person is going to do,
I'm just going to ignore all the
things that are really unlikely.
That could reduce the branching
factor here by doing that.
But, this branching factor
is much harder to handle
because I can't ignore any action
that I have available to me.
The reason is, if I
ignore one action,
it could be that that is
the action that leads to
an infinitely higher reward
than anything I've
seen before, all right?
So, that's the reinforcement
learning problem,
I've gotta try them all.
If I don't, I might miss
the one that is going
to be utopia for me.
All right. So, now
we're going to put in
this social and emotional
reasoning engine
and see how we can use that to help
us guide that action
selection, right?
Remember back to
the start of the talk,
we talked about this emotional
reasoning engine is going
to tell us roughly what to do
in order to get by, right?
Then we're going to do a bunch of
maybe cognitive calculations
after that to help us out.
So, I'm going to take my basic
prime bp and I'm going to just make
a slight modification
in order to make
the presentation a little bit easier.
I'm going to add a random variable
that describes my own action.
I'll call this b prime,
and it's just
deterministically set by a.
So, there is no change
at all in the model,
I'm just adding this
one random variable.
Then I'm going to layer in
a set of random variables.
One for fundamentals
and one for transients,
and I'm going to connect
them through time.
So the transients are going
to evolve through time
according to this impression
formation equation.
So, I say when do I expect
the transient impressions to be
after I see an event taking place?
The fundamental sentiments will
evolve through time as well.
I will admit the fact that
these fundamentals may
be changing slightly.
So if I, for example,
go and start living in
a different culture,
then I need to sort of
shift my fundamental
sentiments a little bit,
so I'll admit that may be happening.
Then I have this red link
between the two
which is my Affect Control Principle.
It says that I believe
that fundamentals and transients
will be close together.
Then I have these green links,
which are my shared cultural
sentiments about things.
So, essentially saying that things
in the world have
fundamental sentiments,
and that's another probability
distribution and that can
take into account the variance
in these fundamental sentiments.
So, given all that,
I can combine them
together and compute
a probability distribution
over fundamentals,
given all of these things
and then I can integrate out
the identities and create
a distribution just
over the behaviors in
this three-dimensional space.
This probability distribution I've
actually labeled as pi because
it's a policy in a way it
tells me what to do next.
This is a probability
distribution in E,
P, and A space,
but it's telling me this is
the emotional signature of the thing
to do next in this situation,
as a probability distribution.
So then I can draw a sample from
this and that's the thing
I should do next.
All right. Or I can seek
the maximum or something like that.
That makes sense? Great. All right.
So, how does this help us?
Well, essentially
from a belief state,
it tells us this function
here says, "Well,
you don't have to actually
consider every possible action,
you should consider actions only that
have this emotional signature."
Because those are the ones that make
sense to the people that
you're interacting with.
They are the socially acceptable
behaviors that you should be taking.
So, the way I imagine this is that
imagine this huge tree is
in the dark which it is,
because we can't draw
the whole thing out and this affect
the reasoning engine
is like shining a beam
of light down through this tree.
So it's saying, these are the things
you should consider next,
don't even think about
these things over here.
So, it's an attentional mechanism.
It's not a way of ranking
all of the actions,
it's a way of saying if I draw
a sample from this distribution,
I'm going to get something
that's in this flashlight beam.
The things in this flashlight
beam are the things that are going to
work at this emotional
consistency level.
So, essentially, this is a
way of solving this problem
by having this shared cultural
information on the side,
that we're using in order
to guide attention.
Okay. This same idea actually comes,
you see it in another branch of
sociological practice theory,
which is fairly far removed,
it seems from
Affect Control Theory or
at least the practitioners of
these theories would say so,
but what's remarkable is that
Bourdieu was mainly one of
the big originators or thinkers in
practice theory described
something called
the Habitus which is very very
similar to what this is doing.
So I'll just read you this quote,
"Responses of the Habitus may be
accompanied by
a strategic calculation,
but these calculations are first
defined without any calculation in
relation to objective potentialities
immediately ascribed in the present,
things to do or not to do,
things to say or not to say."
So those immediate, those objective
potentialities we can describe
them mathematically using
this Affect Control Theory.
What he's describing
this strategic calculation is that
this flashlight beam is not just
illuminating a single action,
it may be illuminating
just a couple of actions,
and within the flashlight beam,
I can then use my cognitive
reasoning processes
in order to try to find what is
the best actual action to
take in order to optimize
over this utility function.
So this we get back to
the utility function that you
were asking about earlier,
I'm still going to try
and optimize this,
but I'm only going to do so within
this subset of
these branches of the tree.
All right. So the idea
is that the humans
will only do this if they have time.
Alright. Time is an important thing,
if time runs out I've got to act,
then I'll just do the thing that's
most emotionally consistent.
If I have time to think
about a little bit,
then I'll wind up, maybe finding
something that benefits
me a little bit more.
Right. People that
do too much of this,
tend to throw things into disarray,
social situations,
but it goes very much
in line with what Bourdieu
was talking about I believe.
Okay. So, that's all the modal
presentation that I'll give,
and I'll walk through
a couple of examples,
I [inaudible] already
[inaudible] most of the time.
So, I might just
go through the first one and
then briefly the second but.
Any questions about the model? Yeah.
>> Just going back to the original
three-dimensional embeddings
let's say of words,
[inaudible] that come from the ACT,
how much coverage of the legs
on do you have there.
How many words have one of
these associated
three-dimensional embeddings?
>> So, there's a number of
different basically depends on
how much money you want
to spend on your study,
but the sociologists have
gathered a large dictionary.
So, the most recent one that
was gathered has I think
800 or somewhere around 800 identity
words and 800 behavior words,
and they're rated by on
the order of 50 individuals,
each one, so you have
a pretty good sample
of how people feel about it.
Yeah. So, those dictionaries exist,
they're also bigger
emotional dictionaries
that are on the order of maybe
10,000 words or something like that,
but not gathered by these same
African troll theorists. So.
>> Yeah, so I'm just thinking about,
could you tag on
these ACT embeddings to
what we use more regularly [inaudible]
more embedding [inaudible] ,
you know, emotional language
modeling [inaudible].
>> Yeah. Actually, so I've had
a few students work
on that problem and I
know a few people who
are working on it.
So, exactly, that idea that would
take a word embeddings model,
and somehow also integrate this.
It may be the case
that if I construct,
let's say a 300 dimensional
word embedding,
that these three-dimensions of
EP and R and in there somewhere,
and so it's not altogether clear
that that is happening though,
because you wind up
with like the movie board embeddings
trained on movie ratings,
for instance, you get the word good
and bad are really close together,
because they are used in
very similar contests.
>> [inaudible].
>> Yeah, that's right.
Yeah. So, I'm not
clear on that yet but.
Yeah.
>> [inaudible] .
>> Right. Yeah?
>> So, if I understand it correctly,
our link in the
terminology you're using,
the initial emotional affects
embedded in this
two-dimensional space
are not dependent on
these relationships.
There's just a word for tutor.
>> That's right.
>> So, have you thought about how
to do this or
think about this in the context
of those changing relationships?
>> Yes. So, I mean, the theory says
it is a linguistic theory
really at its core.
So, the sociologist started
this symbolic interaction.
So, again, based on symbols.
The concept is that,
let say I walk in
a hospital and I see a guy,
a person in a white lab coat.
My cognitive processes
will say, oh doctor,
this is a doctor and
then I'll associate
an emotional fundamental
sentiment with doctors.
This is how I believe doctors are.
Then, using that, I'll compute what I
think this doctor will
probably do to me.
But that concept, that fundamental
sentiment is going to be
the same in any context.
So, if I see a doctor when
I'm taking the subway,
then it'll still be doctor,
but then it'll be
doctor on the subway.
So, that additional context
I can put in as
well and that context would
change things further.
So, let me reiterate that
when I describe the ACP,
remember we just had
this three-dimensional grammar
of actors behaving on objects.
So, I can augment that and
this has been done with
a fourth thing which is
the setting or the context.
So, I can say actor behaving
on object in some setting.
So, student joking with professor in
the classroom is different than
student joking with
professor in the bar.
>> In that context,
what if with other [inaudible]
would it be more natural to include
the same information in the MDP.
I mean, because it's
changing over time.
I mean, just listening
at a single, I mean,
you can embed the entire state
within this context,
but that seems to be much
more difficult to do
than you just have the relationship.
The emotional content be
able to change over time.
>> Yes. So, the tricky thing
is that the states of the MDP,
right this underlying
denotative state,
this x can be very high-dimensional.
This element here can
get really complicated.
But the key thing is that,
these pieces here
always stay the same.
They're always in
this three-dimensional space and
they're comparable within
that three-dimensional space.
So, I don't have to model all
of this context if I can just
get this emotional meaning of things.
So, I can compute a whole
bunch of things just with
the emotional meaning without having
to figure out how the world works.
>> [inaudible] .
>> Okay. So, I think I'm out of time.
So, I think I gave this much
more slowly than I usually do.
What do you want me to do? Should I.
>> [inaudible] .
>> Okay. I'll skip
this prisoner's dilemma stuff,
but this is a canonical,
minimal working example of using
this theory in practice and
I can actually show you
a demo of this game play if
you'd like after the fact.
The other piece that I wanted to
mention was the themis.cog project,
is a project that's in collaboration
with my colleague, Tobias Schroder,
who was the guy who introduced
me the affect control theory,
and he's in Germany at the Potsdam
University of Applied Sciences.
Kim Rogers, who's a sociologist
at Dartmouth College,
and Mei Nagappan, who's a software
engineer at Waterloo with me.
So, this is funded by
this transatlantic platform,
digging in a data challenge.
What we look at here,
is we're looking at
interactions of people
on online collaborative networks
like GitHub, for example.
So, that's our primary target.
So, we look at people interacting
over pieces of code on GitHub,
and then we're really
interested to find out
how do these social and
emotional factors come into
play when people are
trying to actually do
something together
in a social network.
So, I won't give
too many details about that.
So, maybe I'll just
skip these last bits.
This is the affect control theory
version of the group simulator.
So, I can create, instead of
just doing an interaction
between two agents,
I can do an interaction between
a whole group of agents.
Then the blue agent is
the everybody's concept
of the group as a whole,
and I can use
Affect Control Theory to
compute not only what people
will do to one another,
but who they will do it to.
The basic idea is that
people will try to
interact with other people
that are going to
help them confirm their sense
of self the most.
So, we can do some pretty interesting
group simulations with this.
Then, we've gathered
some datasets as well.
So, a few datasets,
so we have a new dataset of
this ratings, actually
GitHub concepts.
So, we're interested in
trying to find out how do
developers on GitHub
rate concepts on GitHub.
So, for instance, the word commit
means something different to
a developer than it does to
someone agreeing to
be married, let say.
These were rated by
50 GitHub developers.
Then, we've done some work on trying
to do some sentiment analysis.
So, based on poll requests
comments on GitHub,
can we extract these
three-dimensional vectors from that?
Then, we have a few other datasets as
well that I've been working with.
So, the basic idea here of
this project is we're going to
have all this data coming in.
We're going to use some NLP to
try to uncover what's going on,
but we're going to guide that using
this affect control theory and
hope that the two things
meet in the middle,
then that will allow us to analyze
these different biases that are
present in these social networks,
and possibly also allow us
to design interventions,
and then artificial
agents that act in
the networks in order to
help the groups become
more effective or have
fewer biases, for example.
So, just to sum up,
a lot of Artificial Intelligence,
I believe is sort of
equating intelligence
with decision theoretic rationality.
But we really know that
emotions are necessary for
intelligence and this low road gives
a heuristic social intelligence
and that social
intelligence allows us to
solve social dilemmas like
the tragedy of
the commons, for example.
Traditional AI people might say well,
this is just the reason that we have
these emotions as humans is
just because we're so dumb.
We just need to have bigger brains
and then we could do everything,
decision theoretically
and we'd be all set.
So, I think that that's fundamentally
incorrect and one of the ways to
see this is by looking at
the different forms of commitment
that people make to one another.
This book by Lawler describes
these commitments as
being instrumental.
So, these are things that
are just have to do with
the practical things like if I
needed to get a coffee
and I'm in a new town,
that I just want to pay money to
a coffee shop and get my coffee.
I don't care which coffee shop it is.
If one coffee shop shuts
down and okay, let's
just go to the next one.
But as soon as I walk into
one coffee shop and I have a little
interaction with the barista,
then my instrumental commitment
turns into an Affective commitment.
So, now I like, "That's
my barista. I like that guy.
He likes me." Next time I
go to the same two coffee shops
and I'd be like,
"Yeah, I want to go to that one."
Then, if that one shuts down,
I'm like, "Oh, no,
my heart is broken.
My favorite barista is gone."
These Affective commitments
are much stronger,
much longer lasting,
and run much deeper.
They're really what motivates humans
to interact with one another,
so they strengthen the bonds
that make them longer-lasting.
They also increased trust between
agents and this leads
to agents being able
to interact with one another
using shorter contracts.
I trust this guy, so I'm
going to do what he says.
That allows agent to be more
efficient and I think this
is regardless of the available
cognitive resources.
So, a group that interacts using
this is always going to do better
than one that doesn't.
So, that's the end of it.
>> So, I know lunch is probably
almost here, if not already here,
but are there any quick questions
for like four minutes for Jesse?
>> Everybody is ready
for lunch and Christmas.
>> So, Jesse has
some free time on
his schedule this afternoon
between one and three.
So, if you do want to book
some time to chat offline,
talk to me, talk to
him, we can figure that
out. Great. Thanks so much.
>> All right.
>> I enjoyed your talk.
>> All right. Thanks.
Yeah, nice to meet you.
>> I was originally scheduled,
I mean to speak to you.